and that's why we use clean and go
because it's fast and it works you can
say that again
now come here and give your husband a
kiss okay ah
Rani um let's just stick to the script
oh no improv no improv all right yeah
it's just the words on the script on the
Pacha here we go and that's why we use
clean and go because it's fast and it
works you can say that again okay cut
Rani
okay talk to you for a second yeah hi
buddy yeah I think that's going really
hard why I said the words that were on
the script
I don't I guess you don't like the kiss
it's not in the script
Rani I know I just I it's an artistic
choice you know try to kiss her no no
it's it's are you trying to kiss know
what's Greg my character wants to kiss
her cuz that's his wife I'm trying to
show that we're a married couple why did
you want to do this okay simple hug over
the shoulder all right one arm official
yeah I could do that and that's why we
clean and go because it's fast and it
works you can say that again but I feel
like you could really see the passion in
that last one very passionate to passion
back story is that's Carol I remember
when I was 16 years old I fell in love
with her we've been married for six
years she's a lawyer
and I'm about to get the reins to my
dad's car wash all right right now
money's not that great but all we have
is our love okay you know that's cute
but this is your backstory you're
trapped in a loveless marriage and
that's my vision and that's why we use
clean and go because it's fast and it
works what are we doing Carol we're
using clean and go no what are we doing
just going through the motions actly
why because people change Greg
we were supposed to be different we were
supposed to but then you started
drinking
you're gonna bring up the drinking thing
because I can't forget about it that was
two months ago
I'm it changed me how do I know that
person won't come back you know what I'm
gonna do say I'm gonna promise you I'm
not promise whenever you talk to me I'm
gonna look you dead in the eyes I
promise when I mean you have a bad day
at work I'm gonna come home with cookie
dough and flowers and I promise I
promised you I'm gonna love you like
we're 16 again I can't love you so much
so much now let's make love right here
and rekindle the fire ah hi I thought
that one was pretty good I thought it
was great we good here it's here it's
here
what get it there I got it
get it yeah you get it it's here